so Greg you're a your career writer I'm
guessing you started writing when you
were maybe like Henry's age so tell us
about the genesis of this story and I
really hope that you did not live next
door to a Glen now there was no Glen I I
wrote this 18 years ago I wrote the
rough draft of this and so it's crazy I
mean I've lived with this screenplay
longer than I have been with my wife and
and I really grew up with this you know
because I wrote it before I you know new
rules or structure I just wrote a story
that I thought was the purest thing that
I could do and I broke all sorts of
rules and and I just wrote this thing
that was a pure expression of who I was
and as I got older my then agents kind
of read it and said okay we're just not
sure what to do with this I'd been very
fortunate and sold a book younger pretty
young and so they kind of steered me
more in a conventional thriller land
because it's that was where to go but
every few years I kept going back to the
story and kind of living with these
characters and you know I grew up on
sensibly I got married I had kids and
little things change like just one
example of that is the scene with Naomi
when susan has Peter in the bathtub and
she hasn't calling out the state
capitals in an early draft before I had
kids she just leaves them in the bathtub
and goes down to plays videogames you
know it's like once I had kids I'm like
well that's not exactly the best idea
you know so I had an experience where my
wife was you know bathing our daughter
and the phone rang another room and she
said just yell out the alphabet really
loud while I go get the phone for a
second and so I kept updating it as I
grew up and finding different textures
and I just kept returning to and I never
sort of let the script go and carried it
through the years until you know 18
years later it was a very fast green
light all of a sudden when everything
aligned up so when did you - in this
life span of 20 years when when did you
get on board when did you come along
three and a half years ago I went to run
production for Sidney Kimmel
Entertainment and I looked at all the
scripts that were there and wasn't that
interested in making any of them except
for - hell or high water that used to be
called command area and this one I
didn't even know that Colin had
expressed
interests in it before Jurassic and
didn't even know that he and I shared a
lot of the same thoughts about some
shaping the script needed to do so I
jumped in and started working on the
script with Greg we did a little draft
and then I got an incoming phone call
that Colin Trevorrow is in post on
Jurassic world and is very interested in
making the book of Henry and my
immediate response was yeah right and
were you worried that he wouldn't be
available because he was in post
undressing no I just figured coming off
a drastic I knew how small this movie
had to be made on a budget level I just
thought that he would never want to
return to that but what was great was he
came in and he said I want to do this
definitely want to do this
here's the window and it's great as a
producer and as a financier as a studio
executive which I was for 15 years to
just know that you have this you know
window of time that you have to get
something done and you just will it into
existence and we willed it into
existence and everybody just rolled up
their sleeves and yeah got universal
focus involves which is amazing and got
Naomi and off we went
child actors can make or break a movie
you know if they aren't strong and it's
a kids movie it's going to go south
pretty quickly but it feels like once
you cast Jayden and Jacob that you
didn't have those worries and even
though it was Maddie's first film I feel
like you surrounded her with these
journeyman actors of 10 and 14 years old
that have made a ton of films and and
perhaps maybe ease that transition a
little bit that was that was definitely
intentional and when I've worked with
children I have always chosen kids who
have been in other films and aren't
disoriented by you know the lights and
the cameras that can disorienting for
all of us yeah and especially with Maddy
who had been on a set before but she
just hadn't she had to emot-- through
her dancing and to her art which he does
beautifully in this movie as well but
for her to be comfortable to surround
her with other kids who could you know
seeing Jacob Tremblay standing and
showing her where the mark is and
pointing where the eyeline of the camera
is is the most adorable thing you can
imagine and you know we were a little
family any of the movie the movie
definitely enters some some challenging
and uncomfortable spaces
regarding you know the treatment of
children and and you know stealing a
childhood away from a child and you'd be
surprised how and I'm sure maybe you
some some of you have noticed this - the
children are often more comfortable
talking about those issues than adults
are and so we were very straightforward
and the way that I am with my kids about
you know this nature of
evil that we were addressing in the film
and and everybody everyone just did a
wonderful job at dialing into to how it
felt to be in this family they became a
family well Colin I'm curious about in
addition to my own there was a lot of
crying in this movie and when you're
working with child actors how do you get
them to those places where they have to
be very authentic to where the viewer
isn't going on you know the kids hamming
it up and crying without exhausting them
I never I actually would have been fine
if nobody cried in this movie and and I
never asked them to cry and and what we
did with the children near that scene
where they're sitting on the bed as we
did it was the one scene we covered with
two cameras okay we managed to get a
camera into the wall of the set so it
wouldn't distract Jacob and just you
know they'd been spending so much time
together and it was right at the end of
the time because the way I scheduled the
film was that Jaden actually was sent
home at a certain point and we finished
shooting the rest of the movie without
him he was gone oh I thought that was
very sad as well for all of us but and
so being able to have those I don't know
how they did it I can't tell you but
whatever actually happened happened very
naturally I think that's the only way
when you're I would love I'm fine as the
tears are out here but putting them up
there is a very dangerous place to put
them so you really want it to come from
a real place I want to commend all of
you as filmmakers for the choices you
made in terms of not showing the abuse
and not showing the violence that that
is almost unprecedented and well done
I'd like to know Greg was that part of
your script in the script was that your
vision or Colin did you shoot it maybe a
little more intense and then in the
editing room go no that's too much well
I never had it
/ I never wanted it to be out there
where it's really clear I think you know
Colin obviously I mean we fine-tune that
all the way through for just how little
I think there was a there was a past we
did where we were like let's not even
say the word right so every time he's on
the verge of it it almost gets cut off
where we were we were backing so that
final balance and then of course all the
shot selection was was calling to figure
out how that rear window aspect of it
would work and what slice were going to
show that's the mean that was all you
know from amazing how the smallest thing
would just tip it too far and yeah just
can see along and you were cognizant of
that early - I remember we all it was a
lot of conversations as we went through
we recognized how obviously how
sensitive it is but also how you know
the tone of the film needed to just make
it the ultimate representation of evil
in a chill in a child's world it had a
Grimm's fairy tale kind of a feeling to
it and in those I mean they put the
children in the oven in those score even
and like you think about it now like
that's really horrible please did you
think you you arrived at that somewhat
separately I'd always thought of this as
sort of a modern fable like I never
thought that this is grounded and I
think Janina killed that in the score
like there's a aspect where like that
it's slightly fantastical I mean we're
not if we're not into magic realism but
the treehouse in the boys room even
though that's you know that that room
exists but oh very elaborate and yeah a
table was a word that we used a lot in
pre-production and you and I talked
about this a little before but I feel
like people missed that in the tunnel
representation and there's a lot of
things like the street names like it's
like spindle lane and longbow and Swan
and like there's little clues that
dinner put there there's obviously
visual clues and then the score and so
we tried to I think create this thing
that had very little to no technology in
the film very do yeah yeah nobody's done
their smartphones and I have a 13 year
old son and his phone is part of his
body so I guess well that was and that
was definitely part of it Kalina eye
binoculars our production designer who
did a beautiful job we we spoke about
making it a film that feels like your
memories and we in conjunction with John
Schwartzman who shot it we shot it on
three perf
35 which obviously is going to make it
feel warm and like something that was
unearthed from you know 1984 and
projected here today and we wanted to
make sure that the children's safe
spaces had a certain whimsical and and
almost antique nature to them these are
these are full of other people's
memories and and things that we remember
and then when they're thrust into the
real world when we go to the hospital
it's harshly real and it's they're
completely taken out of that that safe
space I feel like you know seeing any
story through the eyes of a child which
you know but the for at least the first
half of this movie is it used you in the
same way that you know the height that
you're standing will will give you a
different sense of the space in a room
all of those choices were very carefully
made to make the moment when we take
them out of there be especially scary
thank you all for a wonderful film
thanks for being here to talk about it